This is a big question in psychology. What is intelligence? Some people might
channel Justice Stewart of the United States Supreme Court. And say, well, I
know it when I see it, as he did when he was trying to define obscenity and
pornography. But psychologists have come up with a basic answer. Intelligence
consists of a set of cognitive skills or abilities. Including abstract thinking
and reasoning, problem solving, the ability to understand complex ideas. The
ability to acquire knowledge, and the ability to learn from experience and
adapt to a changing environment. Other less agreed upon intelligent components
are memory, working memory, spatial ability and mathematical ability. So, how
can scientists disagree about the theory of intelligence? Well, let's go to
Greg and can tell us a little more about that.